with godfall releasing recently and with
lots of the lore uncovered i thought i'd
share the tale of this game but
not just the campaign it's more about
the two brothers orrin and macross
lots of the lore we find in the game
really gives us a better explanation of
their thoughts within the moment and
what swayed them to kill the archons in
the first place and why they fought each
other the first section in this video
will explain everything before this
point with the next being after this
point in the game so we can establish a
full cohesive timeline
so to begin the world of aperion was
made from a being called kosumera she
devoured herself and produced her dreams
those dreams then manifested into the
twelve archons
the twelve gods of godfall the gods were
fine as dreams and spirits but
eventually would manifest physical
appearances and since they were part of
the physical mortal realm they had all
the sins of mortality
anger jealousy and ambition because of
this the archons would quarrel with one
another and would fight
but gods don't fight with words they
fight with armies which came the
valorians
first born beings made only to fight and
win these valorians would don
armour called valor plates made to
represent the 12 archons but it wasn't
just the valorians who were created by
the archons it was the tetrarchy of
races the ones we fight in game the neoc
the abyssians and the virgo were all
created by them too
since the valorians in the beginning
were the only option for their forces it
was hard to win battles as they were
very close in power
the tetrarchy was made not just to fight
but for other ideas as well so there was
actual differences in power which meant
battles could be won more easily and the
archons could actually settle disputes
the issue was that the valoreans were
still the top dog they were better than
everybody else says
that's all they knew how to fight and
since war was constantly happening
they're clearly the best at it each of
the archons had alliances so they could
separate their forces
eventually oren and macross would be
separated to the silver main and
hinterclaw alliances technically meaning
they were enemies if the gods had a
dispute
after years of fighting orrin and
makaros would reunite silverman
instructed orrin to find out a weakness
on hinterclaw's top warrior who happened
to meet macros
so they ended up not fighting and
actually talk together as it's been over
a decade since they've seen each other
oren brought up to macros how the world
remains in chaos and destruction as long
as these archons exist
they didn't want this anymore so they
figured it was inevitable that they
would clash with the gods
the issue is that he needed the other
velorians on their side to do this but
it's hard to convince people when you
tell them that the objective is to kill
a god
macros insisted on proving himself so he
fought with his small war band of troops
and
ultimately won which convinced the
majority of the rest if a couple of
valorians can kill a god what about a
couple hundred or a couple thousand even
one by one all the archons started
falling because of this
silver main then phoenix greyhawk
vertigo
hinterclaw illumia mesa typhoon
armistice mobius and aegis horn all 11
of them would fall soon after the other
with bulwark being the very last one
alive you would think the archons would
band together as they were unstoppable
as a group but their natures did not
allow for cooperation
all their greed and jealousy would eat
away at them and no one would group
together thus it was only inevitable
that they would all die
bulwark ended up using tons of abyssians
and vargo to augment his loyal valorians
he was the toughest of the 12 but he
would soon fall too
all would be okay in the world if it
wasn't for the obvious suspicion if we
were to make a tier list the archons
would clearly be at the top with the
valorians in the middle and the
tetrarchy of races at the bottom
if the valorians can kill the ones above
them who's to say the tetrarchy can't
kill the ones above them
that's what worried the valorians did
they just overthrow their masters just
to be overthrown themselves later
so they went to war again as not only
would this solve their worries it would
also cure their insatiable hunger to
fight as once again that's all they knew
was to fight and win
there were always rumors that the
tetrarchy was created to replace the
valorian so
macross ended up using this rumor to end
up feeling the war the valorians started
with the vardals
this terrified the other races and now
everybody was against the valorians
the neoc joined as they saw the
valorians as usurpers and thought it was
morally wrong for them to be the kings
the abyssians joined as they just wanted
to overthrow and kill them they didn't
care for land or alliance they were just
as savage as the valorians just of
course
not as strong another group joined as
well called the flame blood but there's
no records of them so there are more of
the forgotten
group of the tetrarchy orton started
feeling concerned that they were
providing people with the cravings of
fighting and that after they won they
would still need that insatiable hunger
and end up killing each other this is
where macros realized that as a valorian
he didn't have much power but as a god
he could do much
more recreate the whole world no more
tetrarchy no more valorians no more
apparent
a fresh start to the world than to make
it a better place but his method on how
to do that was clearly flawed this is
where the 1000 year war
between oren and macross would start and
as we know it ended in macros winning as
oren we need to battle macros again
which we do by climbing the tower
tower has three realms earth water and
air all of which have these separate
tetrarchies
vargo and earth abyssians in water and
neocon error
but first we have to battle our way to
the seventh sanctum each of the sanctums
served one of each of the major cities
except the seventh who were fused so she
was sealed away until of course we awoke
her again as we need her help she's the
only one who can procure the proper plan
to defeat macros super governors if we
like her or not we have to trust her
clearly the next obvious question is how
do you even become a god in the first
place magrus believes it's through the
rights of ascension so we need to get a
copy of this right so we can understand
what he's doing to actually ascend we
discovered that he needs
loads of ethereum so the easiest way to
prevent his ascension is to
stop his ethereum production the only
issue is that because there's so much
ethereum he needs he enlisted the help
of others to do so which are his four
lieutenants
zamora lunara greaves sun steel and the
gilded commander
killing these four lieutenants gives us
their power and it's enough power to
stop macros himself but to get powerful
enough to actually fight them we're
gonna need the help of a godsmith and
luckily there is one who's in prison
nearby zenun provides us with the
ability to upgrade and enchant our
equipment making us more powerful
most of the game from after this point
is just leveling and getting equipment
so let's talk about those lieutenants we
have to face
zamora is the leader of the vargos and
she controls the earth realm
and now that macross leaves her alone
thanks to their deal she's able to grow
her vargal army which is really her true
end goal
lenara is the embodiment of entropy she
was made along with solaris to protect
the wondrous achievements of the
valorians and anyone who trespasses is
going to have to go through her
greaves on steel is a godsmith not only
is he one of the first godsmiths he's
also one of the best
his mind became tainted with aaron gets
an entitlement because of this and he
eventually was then later exiled from
the valorian society thanks to his
unethical magical experiments
but luckily for him he was given another
chance when makaros recruited him and
finally we come to the gilded commander
macros needed a replacement for oren as
oren ended up leading the troops
macross went through all of his
high-ranking officers to see which one
was fit to run things and the very last
one happened to be chosen
he wasn't the strongest nor the smartest
but he bowed his head and declared
himself unworthy to serve a god this
move macros so much that he recruited
him on the spot this is what earned him
the name
gilded commander all four of them are
macross allies we must defeat as we
clear through them we learn from the
seventh sanctum that this might not be
an ascension we have cut macros power so
substantially that he is just cutting
the ties with ethereum and just doing
the ascension with what he has
it's not enough and not only would it
kill macros it could destroy the whole
world with it and once the ritual starts
someone's going to need to finish it or
we're definitely going to destroy the
world with it the only other person able
to do that would be sanctum
but of course this is worrying as either
sanctum will die or she'll end up
becoming a god after killing all the
lieutenants we battle our way up to the
top part of the tower and meet macross
in person
he is a fairly tough fight but once
defeated sanctum then consumes all the
power of ethereum she's been holding
throughout this whole time and is then
the sacrifice
as we stated doing this ritual is going
to either kill her or make her a god and
in the end it seems that she became a
god signifying the different colored
eyes and the fact that she isn't dead
the ending of this game leaves a lot
remaining what does sanctum think of
godhood what is she gonna do with this
power will she turn on us where does the
story go from here or is it done there's
lots of questions hopefully answered in
time with confirmed expansion in 2021
it's possible this could be expanded on
but now we've reached the final section
of the video as that's the story of
godfall
most of this information did take place
before we started but you could always
chalk that up to
rpg style game design where it's more
about gameplay than it is story with
some of these games
let me know what you think about godfall
and its story in the comments below i
plan to upload some more story related
content on the tetrarchy in the ranks
and especially the other two that
weren't exactly mentioned the crimson
win and the black tide as they're a
little bit interesting as they weren't
originally part of the tetrarchy so they
must have some interesting backstory to
them which is what we're gonna uncover
so yeah look out for that video in the
future and let me know what you thought
like to be if you do enjoy guys
subscribe if you're new take care and
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]